-A few corrections --
I want to do a few corrections
from yesterday.
Yesterday, I was talking about
the children's character -
the children's book character --
excuse me -- Babar,
Babar the Elephant.
I said "Buh-bar,"
and I was told that was wrong.
It's "Bah-bar."
I was saying it like
David Spade's "Flight Attendant"
character.
[ Laughter ]
"Buh-bar."
We were talking about it
because --
because
of the context of Dr. Seus
and how Babar is just
getting away with the fact
that he married
his cousin Celeste.
[ Laughter ]
But that's helpful
'cause he answers to Babar
King of the Elephants,
and Giuliani of the Jungle..
[ Laughter ]
...but not Buh-bar.
Also, I said we --
we referred to "cliffhanger"
in German as "Klippenbuegel.
I was told
by some German viewers
that the German word
for "cliffhanger"
is "Cliffhanger."
[ Laughter ]
So German is a little bit easier
to learn than I thought.
And that Klippenbuegel --
obviously, we're upset
that we got it wrong.
We are gonna take it up with our
on-staff German fact-checker
Klaus Google-Translate.
[ Laughter ]
I was told the way we said i
was basically like
a coat hanger on a cliff,
and as a means of apology,
here's what
that would look like.
Here you go.
[ Laughter ]
The real bad one, though, is
I said the word
"surreptitiously."
I pronounced it
"sir-rip-it-ously"...
which is, of course, the German.
[ Laughter ]
It's pretty bad.
"Sir-rip-it-ously"
is not a good --
I missed both T's,
which is pretty embarrassing
And I came in today
and I said to Shoemaker,
"Did you --
Did you notice that I said
'surreptitishly' --
[chuckles]
Did you notice I said
'surreptitiously' wrong?"
And he said
"No, because I thought
you were saying
a different word."
[ Laughter ]
And I said,
"Yeah, but in context,
didn't you -- didn't you know?
He goes, "I actually think
you also used it wrong."
[ Laughter ]
So that's a real double barrel
Also,
you might have thought tha
once I said it
"sir-rip-it-ously,"
I internally thought,
"That's not right."
Absolutely, 100% not the case.
I said it and thought,
"Nailed it."
[ Laughter ]
Walked home proud of myself.
But, again -- and
I also want to point out that --
you know, when I make mistakes
and you guys call them out
and then I take time on the show
to correct them,
that doesn't mean you should
keep pointing them out.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, if you want to,
that's fine.
That's your pre-go-itive.
[ Laughter ]
But...
...we're just trying
to do our best here.
[ Laughter ]